As sometimes happens, usually about once every
two or three months.
We had a very unfortunate last minute guest
cancelation today. And so in order to not
delay the publication of the show, instead
of hearing from one guest, I'm going to hear
from a few of you. By opening up the phone
lines at six one seven eight three zero 40
750. Starting today with our caller from the
six one seven area code. Caller from six one
seven. What's your name? Where are you calling
from?
Caller from six one seven, I can hear you
opening or closing some kind of cabinet. You
are on live right now.
All right. Bye-Bye. The six one seven, that
was the opportunity and it was a wasted one.
That's very unfortunate. Let's go next to
our caller from the five one two area code.
Who's calling today from five one, two.
Hello? Yeah, who is this? This is Anja. Andrew,
what's going on? Scientists wanted to know,
like like what are you. What what do you think
of them?
These like. Republican and conservatives like
political commentators like Ben Shapiro.
What do I think of them generally?
Yeah, I mean, I I disagree with their politics
and I don't really watch them, but I mean,
I don't know if there's something maybe more
specific you wanted me to say.
Do you think like so like I have some friends
that are like Republican and they wants the
videos and we'll debate. Right. You know,
certain topics or whatever. And I just feel
like some of the things that they're saying
could be dangerous.
Oh, absolutely. Absolutely. Yeah. No, listen,
I mean, I guess I should tend to be more full.
It's not just that I disagree with them. I
do think that particularly because they have
very sort of manipulatable followers. I do
think that some of the ideas that are perpetuated.
I can't say specifically Ben Shapiro or one
or the other because I don't really watch
enough of these shows to be able to say who's
doing it and who's not. But much like Mike
Pence's RNC speech was very dangerous in how
even it was getting Republicans to question
whether we could. It's like almost like Russia,
where they're both trying to get us to question
whether we can safely and accurately do an
election. How many of the ideas espoused on
these Right-Wing shows are dangerous? Some
of them we know have actually moved people
to real world violence. And they're I'm not
suggesting that these shows be illegal. I'm
not suggesting censorship would be great is
if we had a smarter, more educated population
that didn't fall for this stuff in the first
place.
OK. Thank you. All right, you're having me
on the show and keep up the good work.
Thanks, Andrew. I appreciate that. Very nice
to hear from you.